Okay.
In this video we'll see another procedure
for addressing the overfitting issues
in deep neural networks
known as dropout training.
Okay.
So we saw previously that if we are
having over fitting issues in deep neural
networks,
we could use unsupervised retraining.
And now we'll look at the other uh,
uh,
procedure for finding over fitting a
known as to gastric dropout training.
Okay.
So to avoid overfitting, um, again,
the idea is going to be that instead
of directly optimizing what we,
uh, would normally optimize with
backdrop, uh, at our training loss,
we'll try to somehow, uh,
diversity, uh, training procedures.
So I did it does something else.
So for advice, we training,
we had to do some unsupervised learning
as an initialization phase and for
dropout where in a sense going
to cripple the neural network.
Why it's training by removing
stochastically hidden units.
Um, so in the basic
version of dropouts, uh,
what we do is that for each hidden unit,
once we've computed it,
we also independently,
we'll set it to zero.
So essentially a throw
away the actual value,
the hidden units had by say,
multiplying it by zero,
sending it to zero with
a probability of 0.5.
So for instance, if we add this
neural network and uh, imagine that,
uh, we computed the first hidden
there, uh, then once we do that,
we actually for each of the new unit,
uh,
we'll set it to zero with a probability
of 0.5 and we're going to sample this
possibility of sending it
to zero independently for
each hit in unit. And then,
uh, so then some hidden hidden
units will be set to zero.
And then we repeat this procedure for
computing. The second hidden layer,
we compute how hidden units
and then against the Catholic,
we will set some of them
actually to zero instead.
And we continued this until we reached
the output layer where we don't apply
this sort of masking noise.
And so for instance,
one result of this sampling procedure
could be that we would be sending this one
to zero at the first layer and this
one to zero at the second layer,
which means really that we would,
uh,
be computing this subset
of hidden units at the end.
And the connections that are really used
during for propagation would correspond
to those that do not go into or out of
the mass or dropped out hidden units.
As you can see, this is similar to, uh,
the type of noise we would add in
denoising auto in quarters. Uh,
one difference is here that we're doing
this at the hidden a unit level and said
that the input unit level,
and the other difference is that we're
not training on autoencoder here. So what,
when we're doing this,
we're actually doing it while we're doing
backpropagation in supervised learning
with a neural network.
So the impact of this is that now the
hidden units cannot assume that all hidden
units in the same hidden
there are going to be present.
And so they cannot code
that do these other units.
They cannot sort of collaborate to uh,
generate these complicated patterns,
uh, that might be useful for fitting the
training data because now they cannot
expect that all hidden units in the same
hidden there are going to be present.
And so by breaking this a coaptation,
uh,
a behavior that the hidden
units could have, um,
the idea is that now he cheated in
unit will be forced to sort of focus on
extracting a feature which is useful
in general and not just when used in
combination with all hidden units.
They still need to somehow do things that
are different. So there, there is not,
uh, no, uh, uh,
no sort of a collaboration
between the hidden units,
but they cannot develop as complicated,
quite updation patterns between
themselves because they're not,
they're knocking out as soon that aisle
or the other hidden units are going to
be present in some of the other hidden
units will be set to zero stochastically
and a and the basic version, we use 0.5
as the probability of sending two zero.
We could use another probability,
this could be hyper parameter,
but in practice it seems
like 0.5 works really well.
So how does that change the regular
forward and backward propagation?
I'll go to them for training
a neural network. Um,
well let's assume that for
each year than they are.
We've sampled these binary masks,
so we could do this before
doing for propagation.
And I'll call these binary mask.
M a k work gay in Eh,
is an index for the hidden layer will
compute our pre activation like we do bef,
uh,
normally.
But now what we'll do is that will change
the definition of the hidden layer by
incorporating this
multiplication with a zero. If a,
with properties open five decided to set
the head unit to zero. And otherwise,
by multiplying by one, it means we
retain the value of the hidden there.
So this idea of dropping out hidden units,
we can just implement it by multiplying
by disbarring when you factor that we
sample every time we do for propagation.
And next action, you Borden's.
If we put the same
training inputs, uh, here,
uh, uh, at two different
for propagation steps,
we will sample different mass,
or at least we'll sample individual masks,
which will almost certainly be different.
Okay. So that's very important.
The mask always changes.
It is a samples to gasoline and that's
really the only thing that changes in the
algorithm before when we compute the
hidden layer value of hidden unit,
now we compute the activation back there
and then we multiply it by this binary
mass.
Yeah.
And when it comes to doing
backpropagation, again,
the only thing that's going to change
actually are two things that are going to
change.
The first one is that because in the
definition of h came on a swan or Hca,
we were taking the activation,
what used to be the activation
vector and multiplying it by a mask.
Then when we're back propagating,
uh,
the gradient up to the pre activation,
we also need to multiply by the chain
because of the chain rule by the mask,
a vector.
And so this means that at this level,
many of the gradients,
we'll be actually set to zero.
So there won't be a backpropagation,
uh,
that flows through a, so
like no brainer. We'll file,
we'll go through a hidden unit
that has been dropped out.
So this will be the consequence of this.
And we can derive this.
Just buy regular the
regular chain role for, uh,
in the context of a neural network.
So that's the first thing that changes.
And the other thing,
uh,
which doesn't really change but we should
take into account is that this vector
now incorporates the mask.
So this is the mass as
the activation patterns.
That's what we should not forget
that here, this is not the, uh,
this is a vector that contains
a, a lot of zero. On average,
50% of its entries are going to be zero,
because it's the what used to be the
activation vector multiplied by the mask.
Okay. But that's all
that changes. Otherwise,
the regular backpropagation
algorithm, uh, remains, uh,
essentially the same. It's
just the incorporation of
these masks that drops out.
He didn't units.
So that's for training.
When we're training, uh,
we have to sample these mass for every
training example and a yet a slightly
adapt the forward and
backward, uh, equations. Uh,
but at test time, instead of
getting something that's to castic,
what we will do is that we will
replace the masks by their expectation.
And so for instance,
if we sampled republic the 0.5,
we will actually set the hidden unit to
zero and drop it out. Then this, the,
the mask at test time would be a vector
filled with the value of 0.5 because
that's the expectation of
that binary vector. Um,
so actually in the
single hidden layer case,
we can show that this is equivalent
to taking a decision at test time,
which is based on the geometric
average of all neural networks,
single hidden layer neural networks
with uh, all these, uh, plus possible.
Uh, Byron, we masks.
So it's as if we're building this hand
symbol of an exponential number of neural
networks that way combining together
through each or geometric average. So,
just as a reminder, if we have
a number, a and a number be,
if we're taking the geometric average,
it would just be described route up
the product. And just in general,
if you have say three
numbers, then it would be, uh,
the product to the one over three.
So that's the geometric average.
And so we can think of it as
an average in the log space.
Or if I took the log of this would
just be a one over three of the,
some of the lug of these values.
And then we take the exponential back
and that gives us our geometric average.
And so, uh, intuitively
we in machine learning,
we know that the best systems
that rely on machine learning, uh,
or if you want to improve the, the
qualities of the system, one fairly raw,
reliable way of doing that is to
construct and then assemble of men.
We train models.
Well,
we can think of dropout
training as doing this, uh,
in a very efficient way.
We don't actually have to train
an exponential number of models.
We just get them as a byproduct of the
training procedure. Uh, at test time,
uh,
by just taking a,
replacing the mask by this 0.5
probable that this factor of,
of value with the value
of 0.5 in every entry.
That's only true in the single hidden
layer case for multiple hidden there.
This story doesn't really follow
through, but we still see in, uh,
that it,
uh,
we get much better generalization with
this we could combining with combined
this with unsupervised training so we
could do unsupervised for training and
then instead of using regular backup
proper would use dropout backpropagation.
And, um, in general, this procedure, uh,
either with unsurprised retraining of
also alone, uh, allows us to get very,
very good data results in many datasets.
I won't go over them,
but you should consult this paper
by Jeff Hinton and colleagues, uh,
that provide a lot of evidence that this
is a very good, better way of training,
uh, of, uh, training a neural
network to get good a generalization.
And, um, uh,
and I would also add that one disadvantage
of dropout is that training can be
slower. Uh, but it again, it as, uh,
if you're willing to put more
computational time in training,
then Eh,
what we find is that often it will indeed
yield with much better results at a,
at test time. Alright. So
that's it for dropout training.